normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government rumble
under major DDOS attack after CEO pledge
to join Elon Musk to fight woke
censorship this is uh man it gets
interesting every day Rumble tweeted
this out earlier today update we are
currently experiencing a major DDOS
attack our Engineers are investigating
and we will report back here with
updates ad dto attack is a cyber crime
where the attacker floods a server with
internet traffic to prevent users from
accessing connected online services and
sites it disables the site that is
attacked uh one way to easy exp easily
explain this DDOS means distributed
denial of service so I'd like you to
imagine that there's a small door and I
have a handful of oversized novelty
germs and when I try and shove them all
through at once they get jammed in that
door and none of them can get through
now three stoes problem is a is a
Simpsons joke yeah three stes but that's
but that's basically what it is right
yeah they'll try to go through the door
at the same time so a DDOS hits the
server with a ton of requests the server
can't answer them all so then you're
basically stuck in this massive line
behind fake traffic so it really
question is why and who who would do it
who has the capability I think I saw him
post that it was coming I think they had
like a little map up and it was coming
from China really I I think he he
tweeted I could be incorrect but I think
he yeah oh here we go looks like what is
this or it's the world doesn't like
freedom of expression but we will hold
the line here's a map highlighting where
a good portion of the attacks are coming
from North Korea or South Korea that
looks like North Korea I can't believe
that and those tricksters in North Korea
they don't have anything better to do
take Rumble down so these other dots
also also China but hold on here's the
thing you can redirect your attacks to
obus gate where it's coming from and
make it look like it's China it could be
a false flag I'd I'd be more willing to
bet it's us interest trying to shut down
Rumble why Rumble is joining Elon Musk
Elon Musk took away an intelligence
agency asset in manipulating public
opinion because these scumbags are evil
so who has the incentive to attack
Rumble it's not China Rumble provides
free speech which is it's it's
disruptive to the Deep state but you
also St pissed you see free Hong Kong on
Twitter so I don't think China is any
any Ally of that Network either they
don't they're not a big fan of free
speech yeah I imagine the Twitter's in
first structure is a lot bigger than
rumbles I could be wrong but um Rumble
too yeah yeah digital Civil War yeah I
don't know who would who would want it
to have it out for rumble specifically
Services restored earlier today yeah
it's not surprising I mean imagine
people trying to go after YouTube too
which is YouTube's way too big and just
that must be just too difficult and they
no YouTube does get hit yeah they must
yeah they do it's just it's it you the
CEO doesn't tweet it out when it happens
no but people do notice they're they're
they're off often big hits to YouTube
and these things happen and also there
are direct attacks on individual
youtubeers which slow them up and cause
problems for them it's it's crazy the
the level of sophistication you can see
in cyber attacks but if if I had to make
a guess i' I'd lean towards leftist and
fascist um uh organizations on at
behalfs of the US government would
likely be why rebeles being targeted but
they're losing so you add in man 2010s
it's all dominated by the Deep state by
intelligence agencies and the left and
in the beginning of the 2020s we start
to see that shift now especially with
this last year where Elon Musk man I
can't believe it's been a year right
yeah it's been a year since we all
cracked open that Louis the 13th and
sheared when Elon Musk bought the
finally remember when every the first
night and then everybody's like there's
two
genders that's what everybody did
everybody go two genders and then they
just waited for they boys have PES girls
have vaginas God how insane is it that
before Elon Musk bought a previously
Twitter you could get banned for saying
women are not men yeah dude it was you
You' go to sleep being like I don't know
if I'm going to wake up with a Twitter
account in the morning who was it was it
Megan Murphy is her name right me Mur
yeah she was on my low value mail last
week actually she got banned because she
tweeted men are not women though for
four years she was gone that's nuts
insane yeah and and that's that's the
real reason that you know not that Media
Matters in particular is the is the
organization that has the uh you know
has the impulse that to to do this but
they're still protecting a narrative
which is the left's overarching
narrative which which obviously it's
politically correct and it aligns with
what the the federal government and
powers that be want people to think like
there is definitely a
a politically correct narrative that
they're trying to control you know the
ability to discuss this is to I I mean
to call it orwellian is almost it's
almost obviously orwellian and it almost
it's using the word so much we've used
the word so much in the past two years
that we've it's like it's lost meaning
but this stuff really does matter like
it's a big deal that you can say there
are only two genders and not get
punished for that like it should never
have been a thing it there should have
been massive outrage Nationwide but
because it the because of the way that
the censorship has been
instituted there was never like there
was never a time where people were like
okay we really have to you know we
really have to band together and say
something and mus kind of was the guy
that you know said this is the final
this is the last straw you can't kick
the Babylon be off for making jokes you
know and thank goodness he did I mean
people do get kicked off of places for
making jokes still just not TW not X but
well you got you got I just got off of
well I mean I would got demonetized on
YouTube like for life for a podcast clip
on my first strike ever I got uh and
then I got kicked off of Instagram in
the bud yeah this is what this is what
they're looking out for yeah big Tech
platforms know that going after Steven
Crowder is hard not only is he he
massive in terms of his audience he also
has massive resources from this which
provide him great legal defense now you
on the other hand they're probably
thinking look if this guy gets big and
gets up gets several million followers
and starts making millions of dollars
we're not going to be able to stop him
yeah stop him now before he can get big
this is what they're doing I'm going to
be raap a they're just going to have to
put a thing on
my up oh Pig dick
Instagram slob
dick dude but but this but this is this
is the game they're playing and so uh
when all these leftists are like cancel
culture is not real blah blah blah I'm
like most the people who get banned are
small accounts regular working-class
dude opens a Twitter account has a a
couple hundred followers tweets Maga
they ban him yeah yep and this guy has
no one to tell zero recourse yeah you
like all he can tell is his friend at
work being like crazy out here you know
I keep I'm on my eighth Twitter account
or whatever and just go yeah man the
nasty thing about censorship is when you
don't know what's happening like the
Soviet Union I wonder what it was would
have been like to live in 1954 Soviet
Union like how horrifying my parents did
live in 1954 Soviet un it sucked were
they like just not able to talk about
yeah it's like everybody's a spy like
literally the whole thing is that
everybody you know is a like my
grandmother I used to do a joke about
this my grandmother in probably right
around 1954 cuz it was right after the
war she um was living in like I think
Moscow or something in some apartment
building you know and she got a knock on
her door from her neighbor this woman
and This Woman's like hey do you have
you seen my husband like I haven't seen
my husband in a few days have you seen
him and my grandmother's like no haven't
seen him nobody hears from him for 3
years okay until a letter arrives from
the husband to the wife and what
happened is he explained he goes he was
in the lobby of the building and you
know like you live in an apartment
building you're like you know your
neighbors you makeing small talk and he
goes to one of his neighbors goes hey
you want to like hear a joke and the
like oh okay whatever and he tells him a
joke and it was an anti-government joke
and then the neighbor ratted him out and
he got 10 years in Siberia for literally
just telling like you know just in
passing Small Talk want to hear a joke
it's like Soviet gray Russia like let's
lighten things up it's like the stories
I've heard are worse than that but I'm
saying that's 10 years of you know
breaking Stones story is uh the story
that I mentioned that I've told before
is a friend of mine from Ukraine said in
this apartment there's two apartments
they're next to each other it's like an
old communist style Soviet block and
there were there were two families that
lived there and they did not like each
other so one day one family said I got
an idea called the police and said oh
they're making anti-government
statements the next day the whole
apartment was empty man and it makes me
think that guy in the lobby when you're
that that guy went and told the joke to
the guy the guy who is hearing the joke
is could could be thinking like this
could be a government agent testing me
to see if I'm everybody SP right so
you're like it's it's real like Game
Theory where that guy's like well if I
don't report him like I might be tested
right now so if I don't do it then like
you want to be the first person act
almost right and I I guarantee that
there are tons of people in Corporate
America that lived like that all the
time in fear of using the wrong pronoun
or saying the wrong you know saying the
wrong thing or what ever and it's not as
dramatic as people go to the goog but
they just lose their job because they
get they go to HR and HR fires them you
know because they said something
insensitive and so you're you're you're
constantly afraid I can't make this
comment I can't say this and if I don't
call someone out if I do hear something
it could someone could see or overhear
us and then I get implicated too so it's
that fear that keeps everybody in line
that's why it's so important for people
to stand up and say F you I'm not doing
it I'm not doing that at all we pretty
much have kicked the bucket over but I I
could see like a a totalitarian social
media system where if you're watching
video you're online browsing and you see
something that should be reported and
you don't report it they're going to be
like they flag your account that's not
going to happen in the United States
because we got AE of the ball but I
could see that in China being like your
front facing camera turns on and you
just get why did you not record it I'm
not so confident that it's that it's
that it's that it wouldn't happen here
like it's not over here this fight is
not over we live in kind of a bubble so
we see the people that are fighting back
but I I'm not so confident that that's
something that's hit the broader country
yet and understand this
Danny they're already turning your front
facing camera on to take pictures oh for
sure so uh a couple years ago I had I
there's a there's a phone I forgot what
it's called the McLaren phone or
whatever and the front- facing camera is
mechanical it when you turn it on to
take a picture it slide it goes and
slides out so my girlfriend I I I'm like
hey I'm going to get a Galaxy you can
use my phone instead and then she's
browsing a website when all a sudden the
camera comes up and then goes right down
what that means is on a regular
day-to-day basis your front-facing
camera is probably taking pictures of
you for sure so everybody out there I
know what you're doing on those websites
they're probably taking pictures of you
no joke oh those are not flattering
photos facial not not flattering
photos I mean and who knows that picture
but with the cancel culture like I mean
like this is you know more my industry
but
there's no comedy shows or movies
anymore you know like when was the last
like can you name a comedy TV show right
now New York City right now has the
biggest promotion every bus and every
taxi cab right now for Big Bang Theory a
TV show that's not even on anymore and
was never funny to begin with even
regardless of what you even think about
that it's not on right now why are they
promoting it like it's like the new hit
show of like I guess maybe the strike or
what but like it's huge promotion but
like there's no comedy shows anymore is
it because people aren't taking risk R
yes because like you can't take like
nobody wants to take risks because of
like basically the the essentially like
climate and then you know like you who
wants to be caught at work laughing at a
joke that is like going to get you fired
at work you know like you can't talk
like there's New York's already commi
dude you're not going you're not going
to go back go to work and talk around
the last big dude I was 2014 that's why
I'm not there yeah the last like huge
hit comedy movie was 10 years ago what
was it I think it was Ted 2 oh my gosh
and like where it made like really like
in the like in the top like I think it's
in the top 50 something something like
that like there has not been a
blockbuster comed in full of jokes that
put you in jail now I'd say TV show wise
Rick and Morty would uh not get super
offensive but they got rid of Justin
Ryland yeah well exactly I I mean I'll
say uh it's always sun in Philadelphia
Park South Park say new ones new ones
like any sort of like the only things
that are still exist
are these holdovers from literally like
why don't why don't we make a show like
a modern version of Seinfeld called
polish Chuck M sure I don't know if
that's the best title but
um but it might actually be I don't know
yeah maybe maybe maybe it's so bad that
it's good but but sure it's just the
problem is is like in terms of
distribution you know you can get on
YouTube but then they go hey we we just
gave you a strike yeah on Rumble and
then you know we're not far away from
from being able to that for sure are are
your comedy shows like um somber do
people get lit up and laugh standup is
standup is untouched like standup is
obviously like if you go watch standup
on like Comedy Central or something
you'll you like if you go look at like
uh like I do live streams on YouTube for
my shows and sometimes when I'm doing a
live stream like Comedy Central their
YouTube page like this is how bad it's
gotten for them and how badly they
destroyed their brand where they have
11.6 million subscribers on YouTube and
they'll do these standup live streams
and there'll be 300 people
watching because there just like nobody
like the YouTube algorithm stopped
showing their thing to anybody that
subscribed to them because people
rejected it for so long that they're
just like all because they're doing woke
stuff they just at some point everybody
signed up for Comedy Central because
they like Bill Burr and Dave Chappelle
and all that Kevin Hart all that stuff
and then basically right around Trump
which is like a lot of stuff they were
you know all the diversity stuff and
they go hey we need to have this needs
to be more representative and go you
can't just just cuz someone is a certain
category like doesn't make them good at
comedy thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net